nous allons rester au bord de la mer la
bretagne est la région qui compte le
plus de phares en france souvent le
progrès technique qui a pris la relève
des hommes mais à belle-ile-en-mer le
golfeur reste pourtant gardé 24 heures
sur 24
ces hommes font partager la passion de
leur métier aux touristes de passage
rosen kerlan les marques savinaud il a
fallu dix ans pour l'édifier dix ans
avant sa mise en service
en 1835 de ses 52 m le golfeur domine
dalil à tour de rôle c'est un gardien
ouvre les grilles aux visiteurs juste
256 marches à monter pour atteindre la
lanterne
le rythme du peu donc ces deux et clan
audi seront donc ici est le premier
faisceau cristal de roche et cuisine
pour nous au pied ont plus de la plateau
de plus de 12 tonnes qui repose sur un
bain de mercure je vous arrêter pour la
technique
mais selon stationnent aussi pour césar
da ce fascinant wii qui doit il ya plein
d'histoires à raconter et à écouter
il ya une différence quand même à terre
et de puits en mer il y avait des faux
coups de vent pas évident goulphar lui
est à terre mais son rôle est essentiel
ici les gardiens assurent un service 24
heures sur 24 par cars 2 6 heures ce
soir c'est yves guého qui allume les ce
en vue de mettre des rideaux
je ne pense pas que j'aime mambo par
contre sur l' objet d' enlever ce gène
beaucoup de monde pour les protéger du
soleil
j'ai le plus de soleil par temps clair
le phare rayonne à 50 km alentour
d'ici les gardiens contrôle également
une trentaine de balises pendant la
tempête de 87
ils ont enregistré une vague de plus de
16 mètres au large
et puis ils vérifient des émetteurs qui
vont de la pointe bretagne à l'espagne
et qui permettent au bateau de connaître
leur position où il ne voit là le
service de radio navigation est voué à
être remplacé par le satellite
les gardes de nuit seront elles encore
nécessaires les gardiens devront ils à
nouveau cédé face aux progrès techniques
sans doute une chose est sûre ces
lumières là elles ne cesseront pas